[Music]
hi guys I'm pheromone from RuPaul's Drag
Race Season nine in All Stars for and
I'm here with Jake Jake and he wants to
try to become a drag queen today so
we're gonna have some red wine and we're
gonna get all up in this mug with just
whatever we could find at the drugstore
and see you what happens no we're gonna
start first with this foundation stick
so I want you to grab this okay and look
in your little mirror and just and
mirror it all over your face all over
yep make sure to really concentrate it
on those parts all right it's really
thick that's okay
oh this is drag babe you don't you do it
too heavy
cuz are you well blend but I just want
to do this because it looks satisfying
oh yeah coming out beard now you're
gonna take your little PD sponge
okay just work it in it yep it's perfect
now what you want to do is just do two
two until it's evenly spread all over
the face okay faster harder and not down
don't do downward path and Pat it in
okay I would say hat and I'm very new to
this have you ever done drag before no
when I was in high school I went as
Marilyn Monroe for a project so I did a
little lipstick and a wig oh that was
the extension I taken away my drag
experience your memoir yeah yeah don't
be afraid to really just beat that
foundation in there baby you are clearly
a man and we are going to make you
whatever won't have to work some magic
see how it's just very fast and then oh
my God look your beard is gone wow
that's wild
nice none of us on our first time of
doing drag you didn't have five o'clock
shadow in fact mine might be growing in
right now oh don't forget your little
pink ears all I got to do it years - yes
babe of course at this point the next
step would be a cream contour oh my God
look drag so you always want to get the
man out
so like chisel dick jog get that little
cheekbone contour that forehead and it
gets so girly so the line here gets rid
of the double chin and like the chisels
everything nice the line here follows
out your cheekbones and kind of gives
your cheeks some shape and kind of
creates the illusion of a protrusion a
protrusion illusion I like it yeah it
kind of tricked the world into thinking
of cheekbones I see I already see the
points happening yeah you see it do you
feel like a queen yeah I'm starting to
like feel a little Queeny tingly a
little bit yeah I get it you're gonna
just take this is that is that a woman
[Laughter]
[Music]
sure what does that mean what are the
responsibilities of a drag daughter oh
well they're the drag mother has all the
responsibilities not clearly what's your
track name gonna be what should my drag
name be well if you were my daughter
since I'm pheromone I've always wanted a
little baby girl named [ __ ] alone oh
you heard it here first
okay so cue lower-third I am now
pheromones
drag daughter horror moon hormone in the
flesh okay next we're gonna set your
face of powder and relax not for head or
else you're gonna permanently put those
creases in too late I'm a stress more up
you're just a baby girl to see the baby
girl
next
we're gonna go in with some contour
again over the over the cream because if
you notice when you put that powder on
it kind of has some pigment to it so it
takes away a little bit of the contour
you can also have a melt on and just
like like not finish and just wipe it
all off and stay in it then stay inside
if I have a drag queen is staying in her
castle castle like our studio studio for
sure our next step is a good old liquid
liner and you know what hormone this
doesn't get any easier like I've been
doing drag for seven years now and it's
still hard and I still hold my breath
and I still get very deep deep anxiety
from doing this okay so relax your eyes
and kind of go like this like you're
really high okay and instead of dragging
the liner just move your head oh yeah
that's what helps me oh oh no you're
doing on the bottom this is for the top
this is the cat eye I don't know the
signature moan cat eye oh my gosh I am
sorry listen kids
you're all gonna look like this when you
first start and it's fine because
eventually you go from this to this oh
my god you're so good yeah let's let it
try a little bit oh that looks great
babe thank you doing a great job doing
all set
yes please thank you okay bartender can
we get some more when you're available
okay now we're gonna stick these lashes
on normally when you put these on you
want to like trim a little bit so that
it matches your eye but today we are
creating a different
now I don't trust you to try and do this
yourself because you can glue your eye
shut and oh my god so when did you come
out of the closet I'm actually straight
oh yeah I see yeah you can feel the
fantasies you've got a woman yep it's
there
see the thing about fake eyelashes as
it's like kryptonite to straight man
while your eyes are closed keep them
closed even closer and put some lipstick
on yeah yeah you look just like me it's
great just a real baby hormone very very
annoyed that she had to be born but very
thankful for the opportunity to inspire
okay we'll make it work
this is a little bit in my space okay oh
I did yeah oh my god okay you serve us
some face service some face do a little
oh yes give it more well looking
sickening looking gorge looking like a
woman and no one can tell her
differently even with some lipstick on
her teeth I feel it I feel it's pretty
funny to look at I look like yeah like a
drag Reba McIntire or something oh were
like oh my god nope Kelly Osbourne when
there's a problematic team yes oh my god
Kelly Osbourne we sand yeah Farrah thank
you so much for showing me how to use
all this makeup I had no idea how to do
any of it and I feel so confident and
look for your first time ever using it
IMAX
very impressed like it took me a very
long time to like figure out well I
didn't even know that you could set your
face of powders like the first year I
was just signing as hell yeah but the
straight boys love dad but um I'm so
happy I got to do this with you and I
hope that even though you are straight
you're going to continue on with this
legacy of my name I will I will wear
your name proudly I'm gonna give two
thumbs up honestly I am so proud of you
you look gorgeous
well thank you everything see the hair
is on point Thank You makeup is on point
IQ charisma I assume is on point I'll do
it always up it looks good overall good
thank you I give hormone a big thumbs-up
my name is hora Mon